pour garantir une activité sécurisée dans l'espace.
A la différence des autoroutes sur Terre,
il n'y a pas de code de la route dans l'espace.
Absolument aucune règle.
Ouah.
Que pourrait-il bien arriver de mal ?
(Rires)
Ce serait très utile
d'avoir une sorte de carte de la circulation spatiale,
une sorte de Waze pour l'espace que je pourrais consulter
pour voir quel est l'état actuel de la circulation spatiale,
peut-être même le prévoir.
Le problème, cependant,
c'est que si vous demandez à cinq personnes différentes :
« Que se passe-t-il en orbite ?
Où vont les débris ? »,
vous aurez probablement 10 réponses différentes.
Pourquoi donc ?
Parce que l'information sur les objets en orbite n'est pas partagée publiquement.
Et si nous avions un système d'information
accessible à tous, ouvert et transparent, sur la circulation spatiale
qui pourrait informer les gens sur où ces objets sont localisés
afin de maintenir la sécurité et la viabilité de l'espace ?
Et si ce système pouvait être utilisé
pour créer des règles de conduite basées sur l'expérience –
un code de la route spatial ?
J'ai donc développé ASTRIAGraph,
le premier système participatif au monde de surveillance de la circulation spatiale
à l'Université du Texas à Austin.
ASTRIAGraph associe plusieurs sources d'information du monde entier –
gouvernementales, privées, académiques –
et les fait figurer sur une carte unique à laquelle tout le monde peut accéder.
Ici, vous pouvez voir 26 000 objets en orbite autour de la Terre,
de plusieurs sources
et c'est actualisé en quasi temps réel.
Mais, pour en revenir à mon problème de carte de la circulation spatiale,
et si nous n'avons que des informations du gouvernement américain ?
Voici à quoi ressemblerait la carte de la circulation spatiale.
Mais, qu'en pensent les Russes ?
C'est très différent.
Qui a raison ? Qui a tort ?
Qui dois-je croire ?
A qui faire confiance ?
Cela fait partie du problème.
En l'absence de ce cadre de travail pour observer la conduite des acteurs spatiaux,
pour surveiller l'activité dans l'espace –
où ces objets sont localisés –
pour rapprocher ces décalages
et diffuser cette connaissance à tous,
nous risquons, en fait, de perdre notre capacité
à utiliser l'espace pour le bénéfice de l'humanité.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements et exclamations)